NOT A TWEEFR,  THE RESIDENT TRU
WHAT HE CALLS, OF THIG MN
TORY.
FROM THIS RETIJUDGE, K YOOCKS
OFF TO KNOW HOW FRAGILE THINGS H
STORY.
RMIE CONVEYED,  HAD BRBTWO
>> I WAS FIRSTALD BY.ANFORMERUDC
CE OUTSIDE COU THE EVENINGF JAN.
>> CULLEN WAS CALLING FOR
I
IDTHE TOMIAL WORS AN INSTITU
PAM
POLITICS.
>> LG LAW
TELL THE VICE TS.
PRESIDENT I SAID HORITY AT ALL
GET YOUR VOI OTHE  OPENED
A R ACCOUNT, AND TWO MEN
LEGALSIL
ISPROVIDE
THAT I INKE
HELPESIDENTH.
OWE TWR TOT Y SS
>> HE SAYS, DA DON'T HAVTI F JU
HT NOW HOW
NETHE AY?
AND ON JANUARY
H N A ASED SAYCONSTITUTIONPOWETN
ITHER BY RELNERWISE
D MIKE PENCE DID NOT WHAT
SHOULD HAVE EN
R COUNTRY.
TRUMPRSUMULTIPLE
ME AND PUBPENCE IS GOI E THROUG.
AND IF HN'T, THAWI
A SAD DAY FOR OUD FI,
RETURNING TO TOL
THE HOURS LONG SIEGEALLY ELECTI
JUST BEFORE 4:00
7t
T F OF E UNITED STAID,  JR. OF
THE S  306OTES.NA J
OFDA HAS RECEIVE
PENCE.NK. SAID, JUDGE, TH
I SAIDO THE VICE PRESIDENTS THEF
FOR THRER OF MY LIFE.
LUTTIG IS NOW
LOOKING TO4.HE'S PUSHINGTE
THE ELECTORAL COUNT ACT,